I think there's not enough people in
businesses that just keep pushing like
even if you get a pushback no you can't
do that or you know it's going to take
time go no we'll figure out another way
and I think those are the people in my
business that I go yes I'm so glad I've
got you because I think people who don't
take no for an answer or don't take
pushbacks for an answer are the ones
that succeed 100 so I think tenacity
um the second thing that I would do is
clone anybody that is super curious so
one of the things I do I test people in
job interviews and I go have you got any
questions and if they go no I don't
think I have
they don't get the job
anybody that wants to be successful or
is you know going to be good at their
job are curious they're gonna have a
million questions and I want a million
questions I want them to ask me Carrie
what do you do day to day or how much
money do you make or you know and what
are the problems in the business or
what's the first thing you would like me
to do or whatever it is people who ask
questions they're the ones that succeed
the most and they're the ones that do
well in things like pitches if they're
asking their clients questions all the
time tell me about this tell me about
that how do I know about this like like
how do I learn as much as possible about
you and your company they're the ones
that succeed so I think those are the
two things that I mainly focus on is
tenacity and curiosity
um and then lastly I think it's just
enthusiasm I think people that are just
every day positive about their job and I
think obviously we're not all positive
you know I go through days of negativity
and feeling no I don't want to really go
to work today whatever it is but I think
if you have a positive outlook mostly on
life I think you can change the
perception of most most things basically
can you think of many people that you
have that have those category those
characteristics but you would still say
are underperforming like is there a
because we we talk about kind of like
personality traits curiosity and
enthusiasm yeah is there like a kind of
tangible performance element as well
that's Decor related from those things
it kind of tends to go together
tends to go together I think there's a
couple of things that I noticed
repeatedly in those people that they
need to improve on usually those people
aren't very good at
um
delegating work they're like protective
over I can do this I can do that you
know they they force through things and
I guess they're not very good at
delegating work down and working as a
team and things like that but overall
they're usually the high performers I
call them the a players everyone has
like businesses have a plays and B
players and I'll not list who they are
today or anything like that I have many
a players and one of the things that I
always say is if you a good business is
based off how many a players they're
having a business so if you have 30
people in your company and
um 15 of them are a players you've got
very good company I think people usually
have what two three a players
um and it's really hard to get them by
the way
um but yeah I I try to aim as many as
possible
and can you tell in an interview that
someone's going to be an a player or is
it like within a couple of months of
seeing them like when when do you find
out usually I can tell in an interview
and it's usually those three traits I
just mentioned and I usually ask them
when was the last time you pushed
through something to that show tenacity
like you didn't take note you didn't
give up
um have you got any questions curiosity
um and then enthusiasm I just asked them
tell me something that you've done
recently and just see how enthusiastic
they tell and you go you just know that
they are going to be your a players and
you find that prediction holds true when
you see them yeah yes it does the only
thing is a players don't usually stick
around because they become entrepreneurs
they usually go and start their own
businesses and that's what happened with
me I had a lot of people leave and go
start businesses which I'm very proud of
I'm like wow like I hired 100 overall
I've had 140 people in last three years
and so many of them have gone to start
their own businesses and I'm proud of
that because I remember thinking like I
want my people to work here and go and
work for Netflix or Disney or you know
amazing brands or go start their own
businesses and I'll be very very proud
and that's my success metric if I can go
and create that so yeah the fat people
have gone and started their own
businesses is a good thing but it did
mean that I had to constantly replace
people because they they come they learn
and then they move on and go start their
own thing and so yeah a play is a very
very valuable but they're very hard to
keep
hey friends thank you so much for
watching if you enjoyed this clip then
click here for the full unedited episode
and if you like that then do please
consider subscribing to the channel it
means a lot thank you so much and have a
great day